- Okay, thanks. My name's Christian Grose.
From the University of
Southern California.
I'm gonna be talking a little bit
about random lotteries and
redistricting commissions
in the United States,
and this is really fun
because, in my early
career, I spent a lotta time
researching redistricting
with no random component, no lotteries.
And then a lotta my later stuff
has been on lotteries and randomization
and experiments in legislatures.
And so this is kinda bringing
some of that together.
and I'm also kind of interested
in feedback on one particular
part that I'm gonna talk about
that's still in a design phase,
and I'm also gonna talk
about some institutional-design components
of commissions across the United States
that, to me, are like
deliberative assemblies
but that actually have policy outcomes
because they make decisions over mapping.
Okay, and just a little
background on what I'm gonna do.
So, I'm gonna give you some context
about what's going on
in the United States,
where are citizens used to draw maps
for legislative and
congressional and other maps.
I'm gonna then present a research design
that I'm in the middle of and
that I would love feedback on.
I have no data and no results.
I have data. I have no results.
It's a natural experiment,
so the data exists, but I
don't have the results yet,
and I would love feedback on that.
And then the second study
I'm gonna talk about
is one I've done that
is two field experiments
where people were encouraged to apply
for citizens' redistricting commissions.
And so we talked about this
a little bit this morning.
It gets at who are the people
that select into wanting to
serve in citizen assemblies,
wanting to serve in citizen commissions,
and then trying to encourage
the types of people
who might engage in uptake
for those commissions.
And then at the end, I'm
gonna talk a little bit
about some qualitative stuff I've learned
from doing this research,
from also thinking about
these questions over time,
talking to people in
California and Michigan
about processes that happened there
with their citizens'
redistricting commissions.
There's a little bit of
backlash to lotteries
that has come up qualitatively
that I think would be interesting
to talk about at the end.
Okay, so, a little bit of the background.
I mean, I think what the people
who do democratic deliberation
and citizen assemblies...
I think the redistricting
commissions are really nice models
because; here's a picture
of the Michigan Redistricting Commission;
it's the same sorta Zooms
that you've been showing
for citizens' assemblies, right?
The pictures of the commissions
are almost identical
to what we're seeing with
citizens' assemblies,
and these are done in
a handful of locations.
So, redistricting commissions
redraw, typically,
the US house lines,
state legislative lines,
and then occasionally, at
the local level, other lines
in a small number of states
in the United States.
Most states are drawn by
legislatures themselves,
but in some states,
citizens are drawing the lines
and serving on commissions.
It is growing,
and I'll talk about a
couple examples of that.
And then the thing I think
that's most important to this conference
is that the citizens'
commissions to do redistricting
incorporate lotteries,
and they incorporate
lotteries in different ways.
Some of them incorporate lotteries
at the beginning of the process,
and others incorporate
it later in the process,
after there's been a lotta
selection on other criteria,
and they also serve for
a fixed period of time,
but unlike citizens' assemblies,
they serve for, typically,
a decade, right?
They redraw lines, and then they're around
in case there's lawsuits
and they gotta come back
and draw lines again,
so it's actually a fairly...
It's got some fairly similar parallels
to a citizens' assembly,
where citizens are brought in
and they've never really participated
in any, like, major
government decision-making,
like, by law they're not allowed to,
but then they persist
for a while if need be.
All right, so, a little bit of background
on where does this happen.
Here's a map of the United States,
and the four states in the
light blue I wanna point out.
California, Arizona,
Colorado, and Michigan
all have what I would call
our independent commissions.
Arizona's is sorta independent.
I think it's in a different category,
but the three sorta true
citizens' commissions
are California, Colorado, and Michigan.
California's started in 2010
for the 2010 redistricting process.
The second one happened in 2020.
Colorado used a citizens'
commission process in 2020
for the first time.
They have separate commissions
for their congressional lines
than their state legislative lines.
Both of those commissions have
some random-draw component
to the people that end up serving
on the commissions in Colorado.
And then in Michigan, also used
for the first time in 2020,
and in Michigan, there's 13 commissioners.
All of them are randomly assigned
with some blocking and weighting
on party and some other
demographic characteristics.
So there's three states
that the redistricting process
is actually very reflective
of a deliberative citizens'
assembly-style thing.
And then there's some other commissions
in places like Virginia, New York.
They're not really citizens' commissions.
They're often appointed, or
they're some sort of hybrid,
appointed by people who
are elected officials.
I'm gonna talk mostly
about design in California,
Colorado, and Michigan.
All right, and so,
what're the policy choices
that they make, right?
And so they deliberate
like citizens' assemblies,
but they also make policy choices.
They make pretty
significant policy choices.
They're narrow policy
choices in the sense of...
It's a pretty niche area
to focus on mapping and redistricting,
but basically, they create
and they vote on new maps
for legislative districts
following the census.
That's, like, the big policy outcome
that these citizen commissions do.
They also make compliance choices, though,
that have pretty big impacts
on, you know, cost to the states.
There's often lawsuits
around redistricting.
Their decisions could affect
if the state gets sued or not
for the maps that they choose.
They also have to comply with
the Federal Voting Rights Act.
They have to comply with
state-level criteria.
And so there's a lotta complex material
that they have to address,
even though they are citizens
who're engaged in the process.
And then they have lots of deliberation.
They have to deliberate over
what're the communities,
what're called communities of interest,
which is a term around redistricting
that defines, like, what is an area
that people who are citizens think
is important and relevant.
And so they have to go back
and forth with each other,
and they also take a
lot of public comment,
much more public comment
than is done when
legislatures draw the lines,
and that deliberation,
both amongst themselves
and then with the public, I think,
distinguishes the deliberative process
on the redistricting commissions
from how it's done elsewhere.
All right, and just a little bit
on the quantity of deliberation.
These four bars represent
four different states.
Only one of them is a
citizens' commission.
California's independent
citizens' commission is listed
at the top.
The bottom axis is the number
of public hearings
that they held over time,
or excuse me, this is hours not number.
That's the hours of public
hearings that they held
over the course of 2020 through 2022
about the redistricting in their state.
You can see California
has a significant amount.
This is pretty similar
if you look at the other
citizens' commission states too.
They spend a lotta time.
The other states I picked
just as, you know, representative examples
of a Democratic gerrymander,
Republican gerrymander,
and then a Republican gerrymander
that had some voting-rights implications.
New Jersey, Democratic
gerrymander, if you see,
they had very few hours of meetings.
This is where the legislators met,
or excuse me, there's
a politician commission
where the legislators appoint
other legislators and elected officials.
Louisiana and Wisconsin had
the fewest of these four.
And just in general, this is the pattern
if we would look more
broadly across the states,
There is more deliberation
among the citizens' commissions,
and some of that is due to
learning and lack of expertise.
They spend a lotta time
hearing from experts,
hearing from people.
They spend a lotta time
also redoing things
that maybe legislatures
and experts might've done
more quickly and more efficiently,
so there's an inefficiency
that comes out of it
but a deliberative bonus.
All right, and then these institutions
are probably expanding
in the United States.
Like, just this week, in Los Angeles,
the city council, who...
I know most of you're from
the East Coast, but if...
There's, like, a big racist-type scandal
that you may've heard about a year ago.
After that, the city council voted,
I think, Wednesday,
to put on the ballot a citizens'
commission in Los Angeles
to redraw the lines in 2030.
It's sorta like the state's
process but slightly different.
Ohio, you know, this week, is trying
to gather signatures,
put on the ballot a citizens' commission
that is actually pretty
similar to the Michigan process
with a little bit of California put in.
I think the citizen assembly
folks can learn a lot
from the redistricting commission folks,
but I do think the
redistricting commissions
have some unique components to it
that are a little bit
different from the assemblies.
All right, so the study
one that I wanna do...
This is a picture, by the way;
oh, I forget which commission this is;
of one of the redistricting
(chuckles) commissions, yeah.
This is something I haven't designed.
It's a natural experiment.
I'd like to just present my ideas
and get feedback from people
on some measurement issues,
and also, for those of
you who're not academics
who're interested in sort
of the institutional design
for how this works in
all the different places,
we're gonna talk about some
of that in this part too.
So, the question here that
I'm interested in is basically
does serving in deliberative
policy-making institutions
lead to future policy actions
at the individual level,
not at the aggregate level,
but, if you are a citizen
who's randomly chosen
to serve on a citizen's
redistricting commission,
do you then, in the future when
your service is complete...
Do you engage in other policy choices?
Do you do things that...
You have learned
through the deliberative
and citizen process
how to influence policy,
and then you wanna try to influence policy
in other domains later.
And it's a little bit different
than the literature on deliberation,
which looks at sort of what's the impact
on civic engagement.
I also wanna look at that too:
if you're randomly chosen
to serve on a redistricting commission,
do you also then do civic
engagement down the road?
But I'm really interested
in the policy part too.
Once you're picked, once
you get that random draw,
do you then decide that you wanna try
to have an influence
in policy in other ways
after you're no longer serving
on the citizens' commission?
And so we know little bit about this,
and we've heard about it all day,
you know, but there is some evidence
that serving in citizens
deliberative bodies
increases future civic engagement
at the individual level.
You know, if you're on a jury,
you're more likely to vote in the future,
according to some studies.
You know, many publics have some increase
in civic engagement.
Like, Archon Fung says
that they have modest
though possibly can improve
civic engagement outcomes.
And then you know, people
who study legislatures
have shown that people who
serve in one institution
early in their career
carry that service over, and
what they've learned there,
into new institutions.
And so I think that's possibly the case
with citizens' commissions.
And then what I wanna do, as I mentioned,
is sort of go beyond this idea
there's modest improvements
to civic engagement
from individual citizens
participating in the
deliberative processes
but actually that there's policy gains
that they can make by serving.
And so basically, at the individual level,
if I apply to serve
on the California redistricting commission
and I'm chosen randomly,
I'm going to be more likely to get skills
during that two-year process
or that 10-year process
if the state is sued and
they have to come back
that I would not get if
I were not chosen by lot
to serve on the commission,
and I think some of this
is individual-level,
where it's gonna change sort
of the person who's picked.
The citizen will learn.
But I also think some of it
will be coming to them as well,
like, because they've been
elevated to a different status
in terms of serving on the
citizen's commission, which has
a relatively high, you know, impact
and relatively high publicity
within the states that they're done.
All right, so it's pretty straightforward,
what I'm hypothesizing here.
You know, if you're basically drawn
to serve on a redistricting commission
where you've made policy
choices in the past,
in the future, you're
going to try to engage
in more policy action.
Where I would like help
is how do I measure that policy action.
And then if you're also drawn,
you're gonna probably engage
in future civic engagement
as we would expect in the
literature on deliberation.
And so here the unit of
analysis is not the commission
but each individual person
who applies to serve.
All right, and so, the measurement
that I'm interested in here
is the future policy action.
It's sort of tricky,
what the policy action might actually be.
And then I'm also interested
in future civic engagement,
and I might do a survey
with people who've applied
and people who have served
on redistricting commissions
who're randomly chosen or not,
but I'm not sure about that.
And basically, what I'm gonna do
is compare the applicants
who're randomly assigned
to serve on a commission
to those that were not
and then look at these policy outcomes.
And so I'm looking for ideas
for some of these outcome measures
that we could talk about.
All right, couple ideas I have already
is just, you know, engaging
in policy more broadly
in the community, writing op-eds,
writing about public policy
and/or civic engagement
once you've served.
You know, if you're picked to do this,
you then might want to go and write
about what fair processes would be,
what would be better
deliberative processes
in other domains,
how you work with other people,
your ideas about redistricting
10 years later, right,
maybe even going to Ohio
to campaign on behalf of
their ballot initiative
if you've served in Michigan,
things like that,
if you're picked to be on it
versus those that were not.
It's harder to measure this.
You know, I'm gonna try to measure this
via just straightforward Google searches
of news and op-eds and then
also, like, maybe LexisNexis,
and this would be the applicants
who were randomly picked
and the applicants that
were not randomly picked.
The other one that I think'd be
a little bit harder to measure,
but I would like to 'cause
I think it's very likely,
is are they participate
in public forums and panels, right?
These're people that...
Once they've served on these commissions,
they're going to try to
do more in the future,
and that's something else
that I wanna try to measure.
One other one that I wanna measure
is what do they do afterwards, right?
So I think that serving on
these citizens' commissions
will increase their
public service motivation.
I'd like to look at their career changes,
and this is a relatively small group
of people who end up applying
for redistrict commissions
and then either randomly
being picked or not.
The people who are picked to serve,
do they go into nonprofit?
Do they go into advocacy?
Do they leave the private sector?
Or do they stay in the positions
that they were in previously?
And my hypothesis would be
that, once they've served
in a citizen commission,
they may look towards
government, advocacy, nonprofit
more than the private sector,
having had an impact.
- [Audience Member] Yeah,
it's just clarification.
Are all of those commissions
that you were talking about...
Does this selection start in same way
in which the (indistinct)
commission starts?
- No. I'm gonna get to that
in about two slides, yeah.
And I would also like your
help there, (laughs) yeah.
Okay, and then a couple
other things that I can't do,
but I wanna mention it, 'cause
people have suggest this.
So, behavior outcomes we often use
to measure civic engagement
is voting, you know,
serving, running for office,
donating to candidates, right?
All of these things are...
Well, voting's not a prohibition.
Donating to candidates
and running for office
is often prohibited
if you agree to serve
on these commissions,
and it's also a precondition
of applying and being
able to serve altogether.
And then these are also high...
These're people that're sort
of high civic-engaged already
by choosing to apply, right?
And so they're people who
are turning out to vote.
In some states, they're required
to have voted and had a
history of voting in the past.
So, these are kinda
typical behavior outcomes
that we would study in political science,
but we can't do that here,
so that's why I'm looking
at some of these more
creative policy action
and civic engagement outcomes.
The other thing that's a
challenge that I wanna talk about
is the redistricting commissions have
small numbers of
commissioners deliberating
and their processes are different
for how they're selected.
There is a randomization in the lottery
in all of these cases
that I've talked about
in the three US states
and also in some localities
that I'm gonna talk about,
but there's a small number of people,
and then also, those rules vary slightly.
All right, so, here's an
example in California.
I just wanna run through how it works.
And so this is...
You know, what's the
randomization that's going on
in these districts?
And also, this is the state level,
and most of the local
redistricting commissions
in California at the
county and the city level
also work very similarly to this.
This is a picture of all
the people who served.
One of them is my former PhD student,
which I'm very proud of,
that she was randomly drawn
to serve on the redistricting commission,
and she's a professor at Pomona College,
but the selection process is
actually pretty elaborate,
so in 2020, there were about
20,000 people who applied
but didn't complete the
applications, right?
So they had to get reference letters.
They had to explain why
they wanted to do it.
They didn't write the essay, right,
like, the usual stuff like that.
They just filled out their name.
And so the reality of who applied...
There were 2,003 people
who actually applied for the commission
in the state of California.
It's a relatively small number
if you think about how large the state is,
but it's also a lot of people
in terms of raw numbers.
All right, then what happens after that?
And this is in the state law.
The State Bureau of
Audits narrows the pool
to 60 finalists, right?
And so there's not a random
selection at this point
going from 2,003 to 60.
The State Bureau of Audits...
There's a little bit of
randomization in the auditor stage
for which auditors get chosen
to actually review the application,
so there are auditors that
are drawn and block-randomized
based on their party registration
to review the applications
and move them down to 60,
but they evaluate quality:
"Who are these people?
Are they people that have some expertise?
Are they people that can work together?"
There's different criteria
that they have to use.
This is the state auditor
drawing the random part later.
And then the legislature
non-randomly, also,
reduces the pool of applicants to 36,
so this is where the party
leaders of each party
say, "I don't like this person,"
or "This person's a, you
know, secret Democrat"
or "a secret Republican,"
and they eliminate people non-randomly.
And then after that, you get down to 36,
relatively small sample.
And then eight commissioners
are randomly chosen
from the 36,
using block randomization by party,
so you got three Rs, three Ds,
and two people who're other
party or independents,
and they literally do pull bingo balls,
or I mean ping pong
balls or bingo numbers,
out of a hat or out of a thing.
So, what I'm gonna do is
use this and pool data
across the states with the commissions,
but we're talking about
some small numbers, right?
And then look at these
outcomes that I mention.
So, the treatment's, like,
where you randomly picked.
And then of that 36 at the very end,
the control group would be the people
that weren't picked randomly.
Okay, and so here's how it's
done in these three states
but four commissions.
So, California I already talked about.
There're eight commissioners selected.
There's 22 finalists not selected,
and the reason there's 22
is that six people are actually chosen
by the eight people
who're randomly picked.
And so there's 22 control group,
eight who were randomly
selected to choose.
Michigan has a very different
process than California's.
Everyone who applies is
put into a random draw,
and the lottery happens there
without any sort of criteria
to try to move people out
for expertise, or so on.
There's no quality control per se.
They just have to apply.
And then they're randomly drawn.
There is some weighting
on gender, region, and other criteria.
I don't know exactly how that
was done, 'cause it was...
A private auditing firm
was hired to do it in 2020.
I'm trying to find out more about that.
And then they also
block-randomize on party.
And so there's 13 treatment,
people randomly in the
citizens' commission,
147 finalist in Michigan
that were not selected.
Colorado has different commissions
for the congressional
state legislative level,
but again, six people are randomly chosen.
And then 144 finalists are not selected.
And in Colorado,
they also have some appointees
of politicians who serve with them,
but there's no random component of that,
so I'm only focusing on the citizens part.
So in total,
if you pool across all
four of these commissions,
you got 33 people chosen by lot,
456 finalists not chosen by lot.
And then this is
where I would leverage the
control versus the treatment
for the policy outcomes or
the civic engagement outcomes
in the future.
One other, much larger table,
so just direct your eyes
to LA County, Santa Barbara, San Diego.
There are also very similar
ones at the local level
that I would like to
look at in California.
They're expanding a lot, too,
and here it's very similar
to what I talked about in California.
We're starting to get to where
we have a little bit more...
There's 54 people chosen by
lot across these localities.
LA County and San Diego County...
Not only am I interested in this
as a professor and researcher.
I also was a consultant
for San Diego County's
redistricting process,
and so, they used a commission
for the first time in 2020,
where eight people were randomly chosen
and then 50 finalists, not selected.
This is basically how these
institutions are designed,
for those who are interested in that,
from translating over
to citizens' assemblies,
but then also, I think,
it creates some real
leverage that I wanna look at
in terms of the political
science outcomes.
My concern is, of course, these
are different institutions
with somewhat different designs,
even though there's randomization,
really small N, right?
And so I can pool this and look at it.
But then you know, I'm interested
in what feedback you have,
besides the sample's too small to bother,
that I could still try to leverage this.
Okay, and then I wanna talk a little bit
about a second set of studies
that I've done already
that might help you to figure
out who are these people,
like, who wants to serve
on a redistricting citizens' commission.
Who wants to serve in a...
Who wants to go to a
citizens' assembly? Right?
Who decides to apply
for something like this?
'Cause you can't be an elected official.
You can't run for office
in the future, right?
You have to be interested in politics
and wanna make a difference,
but you have never
displayed any other behavior
suggesting you wanna do
(chuckles) that in your life,
and you know, there's prohibitions
on donating to candidates
and things like that.
So it's a really
interesting group of people,
and I'm trying to figure
out who these people are.
All right, and so this study is based
on two field experiments that
I did in the 2020 process
in California in Los Angeles County
that basically examined
uptake in participation,
like, who applies,
and can we encourage more people to apply
and see who those people are.
All right, and so the argument
here is just basically
people who are publicly service motivated
or who have financial incentives
may be willing to serve, right?
And so the experiment
is gonna test those two
different questions.
Do you wanna serve on a
redistricting citizens commission
because you find out
that you might get paid
and it's an additional...
'Cause there is limited
pay on all of these,
the financial incentive may
spur you to participate.
Or do you wanna do it
out of public service?
If you give them a sort of "this'll help."
This is, like, a classic
civic engagement message
that you might do with
a GOTV-style experiment.
Will they serve?
All right, I won't go
into all of the results,
but the punchline is
the public service
motivation encouraged people
to sign up and apply.
The financial incentive did not.
The financial incentive had no impact,
financial incentive
meaning just telling them
how much they will be
paid if they are chosen,
not any additional incentive.
The public service message
mixed with the financial message
also made no difference in terms of the...
It was similar to the
public service effect.
All right, and so, what
the two experiments were...
One, I partnered with a good
government organization,
who was concerned about the
number of people who would apply
for the California
redistricting commission,
and we embedded this encouragement
experiment with them.
We invited academic experts,
primarily social science professors
at University of California institutions
and a handful of other private
institutions in the state,
and it was fielded in summer of 2019.
Told them about the process,
gave 'em the application,
and gave 'em those different messages.
I did a parallel experiment
for the Los Angeles
County Commission only.
That was also in partnership
with a good government
organization based in LA,
a different group,
that was encouraging Asian
American and Latino members
of their good government organization
to apply, and the exact same
experiment was done there.
Okay, and the outcome variable here
is really straightforward:
"Did the person apply or not?"
As I mentioned, there's a control group
of people who didn't
receive any message at all
from the non-partisan organizations.
There's one that got the public
service motivation message,
the financial message,
and the one that got the two together.
This was the public service
message down here in the square:
"Commissioners who apply and
are selected should be driven
by motivation toward public service
in order to make California a better place
and shape the state's future."
This text is pretty similar
to the messaging that the
state was using itself
to get people to serve.
It also included a brief
description, deadline,
links to the application,
and all of that stuff.
Same message with the
links and the details
and how you apply was
given to a different group
that was randomized,
and this just said what the
amount you would get paid
if you served.
It's actually not very high
for the number of hours,
if you remember that figure
I (laughs) showed at the beginning
with the total number of hour,
but it's not nothing either.
It's actually substantial
if you think about,
like, the median income
of California, right?
And so this is just saying
how much you may get paid
and what the people were
paid in the previous one,
and this is per diem, by the way.
This isn't a salary, but this is...
You know, there's a little
bit of a financial incentive.
This is also true, right?
So this is actually,
like, factual information.
And then both messages.
And so the results I mentioned.
Financial incentive had no impact at all,
but the public service message, PSM,
people were 1.4 percentage
points more likely
to apply to serve on
the citizens' commission
than the control group.
And then you know,
the other conditions just
didn't make a difference,
and that was the case in
the statewide experiment
and also the case in the
Los Angeles experiment
with a different sample of people.
- [Audience Member] Just
a very quick question.
Can you remind me how many hours,
like, per week or per year (indistinct)?
- Oh, yeah, so, it depends.
Like, in the year in which
they're redistricting,
it's probably 8-to-10-hour meetings
about twice a week, sometimes longer.
Like, at the very end,
when they're almost done,
like in November and December of 2021,
it was probably 10-hour
meetings almost every day:
Monday, Tuesday, Thursday, Friday.
And then they're done. And then once...
Like, in the case of California,
they completed the maps,
I think, on December 23rd.
And then there was very little...
Then they went to Sacramento,
and they delivered the maps.
And then there's not much left to do.
I think they had a party.
And then there was basically meetings
every month or two, right?
And that's more of, like,
what did they learn,
kinda coming together occasionally,
and now they hardly
ever meet at all, right?
But they do stand for a decade
in case there's a need to come back,
like, in case one of
the maps gets a lawsuit,
so like, in Michigan right now,
there is a lawsuit against the map
that's in court,
and if that succeeds, they
will have to come back again
and do 10-hour days three days a week
for probably about a month or so, yeah,
so it's a very high-intensity commitment
for a short period of time, yeah.
But it's a little bit like
the deliberative assemblies
that go on for quite a long time,
where you bring people back.
- [Audience Member] Did you look
at heterogeneous treatment effects?
'Cause you've assumed
that, like, the baseline income
that's under the midpoint
of your financial treatment
would be positively incentivized,
while above it would be...
And that would net out, right?
- No, that's a great idea, and I have,
and because most of the
sample for the statewide study
are public employees
'cause they're professors
at public universities,
the data on their income is available,
so I can do that, but I haven't,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know, concluding, couple
things I wanna talk about,
like what have I learned from some of this
and also what have I
learned from observing.
Right, if you're interested
in randomization and
commissions, if you're interested
in citizens' assemblies and deliberation,
what can we learn from
Michigan, California,
Colorado, these localities?
So, few things.
You know, qualitatively,
there've actually been some
concerns raised by advocates,
and by advocates, I mean
people who were on the ground,
good government groups,
or advocates in the sense of
groups who were interested
in, you know, increasing diversity
in the redistricting process,
who were concerned about voting rights.
In general, they've been considered
very positive, by the way,
so in general,
the commission processes have
been rated highly by advocates
compared to when
legislatures draw the lines,
but within that, the
discussion around randomization
has been, I think, a little misguided
in the policy community
in some of the states,
and so, just for example, in California,
if you recall,
is a really racially and
gender-and-disability-diverse group
of people who were selected to serve;
however, in the first
draw of the eight people
who were randomly chosen in California,
it was very diverse
in terms of Asian
American, Black, and white,
but there were no Latino
members who were chosen to serve
through the random draw,
and that's just small sample.
Part of it is the number
of people who applied
and sorta differential
in people who applied,
but part of it was just the small sample.
You occasionally get these outcomes
that're not demographically representative
when you're only randomly
drawing eight people, right?
And so there's a huge...
This is, like, a huge problem
in a state like California,
where nearly 40% of the
population is Latino.
And then the next six who're chosen,
nearly all of them were Latino,
which created demographic balance,
but because that happened,
just that statistical quirk
of the, you know, small
sample and randomization,
a lot of Latino advocacy
groups have expressed concern
about randomization, right,
'cause of that one observed outcome,
even though of course randomization,
assuming it was done fairly,
is fair, right?
And so that's something
that is a thing that just...
Whenever you're dealing with randomization
in deliberative groups
and it's a small sample
and there may be a lack
of demographic diversity
that coincidentally happens,
it's gonna raise a lotta fairness issues.
In Michigan, I talked to some people there
who were concerned about randomization
from a quality standpoint,
so because Michigan has no
vetting about who applies;
you just apply, and then they pick people;
there were some concerns raised
that some commissioners were
higher-quality than others,
and unlike a deliberative assembly,
there's no real time to learn.
I mean, there's time to learn,
but you really have to
start making policy choices
by serving as opposed to
kinda getting up to speed.
Couple things that're important
in all of these states is staff.
And so I think this is relevant
for deliberative assemblies
and any other kinda citizens' assembly
that you wanna think about.
They all hire staff,
and it's their choice of
staff of who they hire,
but those staff can really be important
the same way that there's a bureaucracy
for an elected legislature
that, you know, the
legislatures will put in
that're semi-permanent
in the case of these commissions.
Having the experts that they
can hire can be important,
but then the ultimate
principal are these citizens
who're effectively making the decisions.
Also, in Michigan, the secretary of state,
I thought, wisely,
and interesting from a
social science standpoint;
she was a former professor;
she randomly sent invitations
to all, or a subset,
of people in Michigan to
encourage them to apply.
Trying to get my hands on those data.
Those letters have also
received some negative feedback
because some people thought
that the government was
requiring them to apply.
Some people applied
and then actually made
it to the next stage
and were like, "I don't
know what's going on.
I don't wanna do this."
So there's a little bit of things.
When you're incorporating lotteries
into public decision-making,
you know, whatever happens
in one or two anecdotes
will actually inform the views
of how people respond to them,
so just think about that,
for those of you thinking
about randomization and
democratic deliberation.
And this is what I mentioned.
There's some emerging
pushback on some of this,
but also, I think, positively,
there're a lotta good government groups
pushing these reforms.
Like, the Ohio proposal for
the commission has this.
They have lotteries embedded within it
because it does actually
increase fairness, right?
But then there are equity
concerns about who applies, right?
And so if you have an
unrepresentative set of applications,
then the outcome may not appear equitable
or is not equitable.
Okay, that's all I've got.
I'm happy to take questions,
but it's just been really fun.
I appreciate Allie, thank
you for organizing this.
That's study two's of a paper
I've been meaning to work on,
and this caused me to get going on it.
And then this conference
has made me think a lot
about ways of incorporating
redistrict commissions,
democratic deliberation,
and citizen assemblies.
(audience applauds)
- [Mark] Hi, Mark Orton.
So, I guess I have two questions.
The first is can you
think of other examples
of similar sorts of bodies
to redistricting commissions
that have similar properties
that're other examples in our society
where these things are used.
- Do you mean, like,
having citizens in general?
Or, like, the randomization component
combined with some sort of
other selection process?
- [Mark] I mean, I guess it's,
you know, similar bodies.
It's, like, a kind of
independent citizens' body
doing a specific task
in the context of the government, I guess.
- No, off the top of my head, I cannot,
though I'm sure they exist, but I think
my head is so in the redistricting
commissions right now
that I'm not thinking about it,
so lemme get back to you on that.
- [Mark] Okay, and then
the second question is
you mentioned, in Michigan,
there were concerns
about the quality of the people
'cause it was just pure random.
What was the experience of how
that commission functioned?
- Yeah, I mean, I actually
think it worked out pretty well.
I think, on balance,
the commission did well.
I do think there were some people
who participated more heavily.
What ends up happening
is, if you have the true randomization
as your selection process,
it probably privileges a few more
of the people that just
were randomly chosen
who were the more active
participants, right?
There are a couple people who
didn't attend as frequently.
That happened with one
person in California as well.
I also think some of the
criticism in Michigan
is coming from people with interest
in the outcome of the maps.
I mention that not because I
think the criticism is correct
as much as it's something
that was discussed and
came up during the process,
like, "Who are these people?
Why is this person not
attending every meeting?" right,
so any way that you can kind of attack,
you know, if you're the legislature
and you would like to keep the map
or you have your own interest
and you're not drawing the line,
so some of it is that strategy.
But I also think some of it
is some the people applied
and, you know, they weren't really sure
what they wanted to do and
if they wanted to do it.
And so there's also lotta drop-off.
So, people initially applied,
and then once they kinda found
out what it was really about,
they didn't move on to the next stage,
but in California
and other places where the
selection that's not random
weeds out people who maybe
are less interested early,
that's less of a problem.
(audience member speaks indistinctly)
- [Audience Member] This is
a theoretical (indistinct),
but was there any empirical evidence
that any groups were attempting
to co-opt the citizens' assembly
or feed them information
or, you know, make promises
to them or anything like that?
Or was that control well-controlled?
- So, there wasn't evidence
of the latter as far as I know
in any of the states,
but I do think that...
And I think this is interesting
if we think about citizen
assemblies broadly.
So, the redistrict commissions
are very transparent by law
in all three of these states,
and they have to be,
and as a result, you know,
people with interest in the maps
know who the commissioners are.
And they have very strict
laws on communications
on what they're allowed to do,
but the public comments
can become effectively
public lobbying about
what other people want,
so I think that your first
part of the question...
You know, there's evidence
from the first California experience,
in 2010, that people were
putting forward ideas.
In 2020, the mayor of San Jose
called the commission
several times and talked
about how San Jose (laughs) is a community
that must be together
because, I think, he wanted
to run for Congress, right?
And so that's actually a pretty...
And they didn't end up following
what he suggested either,
which is interesting,
but there is a way to
influence these citizens,
but it all has to happen
in a public meeting.
And so to me, that is a little bit more...
Even though potentially
normatively concerning,
the empirical evidence would
say we all can observe that
as opposed to...
And you know, if a
legislature's drawing the line
in Wisconsin, we can't
observe what is happening
and who's lobbying whom about that,
so I think yeah.
But I think there's some
empirical evidence of that.
On the other hand, the negative feedback
in multiple states, all
three states actually;
I haven't talked about Colorado;
from some of the parties and
some specific elected officials
would suggest that there may be
less empirical evidence of that,
because the negative
(chuckles) feedback came
after the maps were done, yeah.
- [Philip] Hi, Philip Lindsay
from the Democracy Innovation
Hub at Bard College.
Two questions.
The first one is, so many times, I think,
because we don't really train facilitators
in our society at large;
we don't think about the facilitators;
they're not included.
I'm curious if there were
facilitators in these processes
and how that played
into, you know, how much
time people were speaking.
And then the second
question is I always imagine
that, if you get randomly
selected citizens,
you bring 'em together and
say, "Hey, you should...
We're gonna redraw the maps.
There's all this gerrymandering,"
that, at some point,
some citizens would
propose some other form
of proportional representation
for their state,
and I'm wondering if that
conversation ever came up.
Or is there just...
Is it just so unconstitutional
at the state level?
Or there's so many hurdles
that, like, the conversation
would never go near that?
- Yeah, that's a really good point.
I mean, on the first one,
you know, very slightly,
but on balance, there's not
what I would call facilitators.
Like, so they're on there. They serve.
They do hire an executive director.
They hire legal staff, right?
There are staff who help
guide them in specific things,
but typically, they're
leading the meetings.
And so what happened...
What California did
was they rotated the
chair of their committee.
They just chose to do that early on.
And then that person was
effectively the facilitator
for the other 13 commissioners
during the meetings.
Because all of these three states
and then if it passes in
Ohio and the localities,
there's some pretty
strict rules in the law
about what they can talk about,
when it has to get done,
deadlines for completion.
I wouldn't call that facilitation
as much as they had to
have public comment.
They had to be in
deliberation with each other,
and then they had to be in
deliberation with the public,
or at least, they had to hear the public,
they didn't necessarily have to respond,
and then that would
repeat again and again.
And so because of that, the
deliberation almost happened
because they were required by law,
even without a facilitator,
but certainly, the chair
ended up facilitating a lot,
and you could see the
commissioner, who was the chair,
would often step back
and not speak as much
while the other 13 were talking.
There are also some people
who are more like...
They're just the leaders that
emerged through the process
and were a little more
dominant in the process
towards guiding things and undoing things
in all of the different states:
Colorado, Michigan, and California.
But on to your second question
is, like, "Does this
make them wanna just do
electoral system change?"
That's a really good idea,
and that's kinda what I want to get
out of the policy action.
So, they can't do that.
They can't, in the commission, say,
"We wanna get rid of
single-member districts.
This is frustrating."
They're bound by the law, but some of...
Anecdotally, I do know some
of the commissioners who served in 2020
have already attended conferences
about election-system change,
proportional representation,
multi-member districts.
You know, this sort of did,
kinda consistent with my hypothesis...
I think I'm gonna measure
that outcome specifically.
Some of them are now working
on these sort of election systems,
broad policy changes
that they may like to see
or at least wanna be
part of the conversation.
- [Kevin] Thanks so much, yeah.
So, Kevin Elliott from here at Yale.
Yeah, so, just on this last point.
So, when you were trying to
differentiate civic engagement
from policy actions,
I was a little puzzled at first,
and then when you began talking about it,
it became clearer 'cause I
thought about it in terms of...
The policy actions that
you're talking about
are things that're specifically
related to redistricting
it seems like.
In other words,
they've acquired policy expertise,
issue expertise, on that.
It seems like all of
the suggested measures
had to do specifically
with their deployment
of this specific-issue
expertise that they had,
and when you think about that
as opposed to more general
civic engagement...
That makes sense to me
as a distinction, right?
So it'd be civic engagement
on the thing that they are
now relative experts on
as opposed to civic
engagement more broadly.
- Yeah, that's a good point.
I mean, I was thinking
of civic engagement more
in kinda the traditional literature
of, like, how we've measured it
and then the policy parts separately.
I do think that the policy
actions that you would expect
coming out of service
and being randomly drawn
would be on the...
I'd say, like, the broader
election-system topics.
It may not be about redistricting
precisely but could be;
however, again, I have anecdotal evidence,
and I've not collected the data yet,
that some of them
have done other public
policy-style things post-service.
Like, some of the people served
on the 2020, excuse me, the
2010, California commission,
who are now done, who were randomly drawn,
they're on panels
about what can California
teach Arizona, right?
And it's not about redistricting.
It's about sort of just
having policy discussions
and things of that nature.
Some of this is also...
It's, like, you have to
figure out what's the supply
versus the demand, right?
Like, how much of this
is the individual level:
person serves, and now
they wanna go and engage
in policy in other domains?
Or is this people are now seeking them out
because, you know, they
watched them, for a year, do
deliberative meetings with other citizens?
And that's harder for me to tease out,
but I do think this translates
beyond just redistricting.
I think it translates
to policy action broadly
with the limitations of
you can't run for office,
I think, in all the states,
for almost a decade or more.
You're limited to do,
like, straightforward
political activities.
- [Kevin] But it's
leveraging your experience.
I think that that's-
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- (indistinct) common.
That's still a common thread.
- That's a good point, yeah.
So, they actually have
much more experience
that they've gained via skills
that they wouldn't have had
before they served, yeah, yeah.
- [Moderator] Okay,
great. Thank (indistinct).
(audience applauds)